[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres en séance
plénière les élus de la collectivité ont
débattu du contrat de confiance et
tailles département sur la programmation
des finances publiques 2018 2022
ce dispositif prévoit la limitation
d'évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités à 1,2
pour cent par an après négociations le
département de la réunion obtient une
révision du taux à 1,32 pour cent on ne
peut pas demander au département de la
réunion avec tout
tous les désavantages que nous avons à
tous les efforts que notre demande on
peut pas demander ces mêmes efforts des
pentes mannarino au département de
métropole
ça laisse des marges de manoeuvre dans
le cadre d'abord de ce que le
département faisait en action sociale ça
ne les touche pas et ça permet même au
cas où il ya des situations encore plus
importante de pouvoir inventer de
nouveaux dispositifs
les élus ont également adopté à
l'unanimité une demande de maintien des
fonds structurels européens en faveur de
l'agriculture réunionnaise
aujourd'hui à la cuisine centrale de
bras panon l'ingrédient principal des
plats cuisinés c'est le va quoi
l'association autour du va quoi présente
ses recherches gastronomique et les
possibilités de développement de cette
filière en apéritif
accra de papa et chips de papa
ensuite l'entrée salade de papaye saumon
en plat alors un sauté de boulay et un
carré de porc et enfin pas l'originalité
c'est des textures et des goûts qu'on
retrouve pas forcément ailleurs
un super projet sur tout que c'est donc
l entrain de même ce projet l'un d'eux
va quoi ils utilisés dans le monde
entier comme aliment santé
il contient très peu de glucides des
fibres là aussi il y a des vitamines c
et d et b aussi qu'ils sont utiles pour
le système nerveux extrêmement santé
qu'il ya mène une centaine de sérénité
un stand zénitude dans sa consommation
c'est en musique que ses élèves fête les
10 ans de leur collège situé à saint
benoît le collège guy-môquet est un
établissement tourné vers le
développement durable
les collégiens ont reçu le label
national de l'éco collège le département
joue pleinement son envol s'investit aux
côtés de l'équipe éducative pour que nos
enfants puissent connaître bien être et
travailler dans de très bonnes
conditions c'est ça importe encore c'est
que notre jeunesse de mai je se dire
mais ce collège j'étais et aujourd'hui
je suis devenu
moi même j'ai une activité j'ai une
belle réussite à travers aussi ce
passage dans ce collège c'est un village
itinérant dédié au monde agricole et à
l'europe avec ses ateliers participatifs
120 collégiens ont pu découvrir les
formations et les métiers dans le monde
agricole
une filière en plein développement
soutenu par les aides européennes
aujourd'hui le département a voulu
sensibiliser les collégiens au potentiel
que peut leur a offert le monde agricole
et comprendre comment l'europe au
travers du feader intervient que ce soit
au développement des filières le
développement des os et jusqu'aux grands
projets d'irrigation du littoral ouest
le bonus de cette semaine c'est une
balade sur terre et dans les airs à la
découverte de la rd42 il est à cordes
mais
[Musique]
un programme à revoir dans son
intégralité dans l'émission des routes
et des hommes sur le site du département
[Musique]